des pertes et la californie je veux
aller sur la côte est
je veux aller là où est la culture
comment améliorer les filles 6 rue note
wang wenxi rouge était pas libre dans le
même failli être admise maman situe près
les six titres a ledge avec ton équipe
de travail pas au city collège ensuite
en prison et puis tu reviens aussi dit
période j'ai peut-être que tu reprendras
de rezé et ne t'attends pas lady bird
est ce que c'est votre vrai prénom
oui pourquoi est-ce que c'est entre
guillemets parce que je me suis donné à
moi même
il m'a été donné parfois les people qui
toujours quelle vie du mauvais côté de
la barrière
mais j'ai toujours cru musical vie et la
mort mais elle parlait vraiment de la
barrière du chemin de fer mais vous avez
fait ça prend du courage c'est très
anarchique rodez magazine en place elle
a beaucoup de cartes amer et les
chaleureuses mais aussi effrayant on
peut pas être chaleureux et rayant
exactement la mer
donc vous n'êtes intéressé par aucune
université catholique
aucune je veux une école comme hier mais
pas y être parce que ça m'étonnerait que
je puisse y en a où il n'avait aucune
chance d'y entrer c'est sûr c'était
fatiguant que ce soir je suis pas fait à
ce que tu traînes les pièges étaient
toujours exacts à 2 30 g pas crier cher
et c'est parfait vous avez toutes les
deux une forte personnalité
[Musique]
6 quel est l'âge normal pour avoir des
rapports sexuels à des rapports sexuels
puis brett je voulais juste que ce soit
officiel pourquoi tu vas avoir beaucoup
de celle ci sera pas spécialement table
nous avons peur de ne jamais pouvoir
échapper à notre passé quoi on donne ce
n'est jamais suffisant sait jamais s'il
en visant nous avons peur de ce que
l'avenir nous réserve
nous avons peur de ne pas être aimé
qu'il est incapable de faire quoi que ce
soit sans être le centre d'attention
pas être apprécié web à toi les san
lameer ils sont complètement fous rires
pris une mauvaise décision at 9 ans que
dans telle décision ne veulent pas
réussi je veux que tu sois la meilleure
version possible de toi même
[Musique]
tête que c'est ça mais en version plus
ce que j'aimerais beaucoup c'est
participer aux olympiades de mathml et
là ne sont pas votre pré fort ils ne le
sont pas pour l'instant
[Musique]
oui